hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to what just might be the
greatest video I have ever made on this
channel yes it is time to play those
time-honored spongebob games that we all
know and love actually when I was
playing the meme video uh or when I was
making the me video I didn't expect
there to be so many Shrek related games
all I expected was that I was gonna play
some stupid games and those were the
ones that popped up so I was thinking
about another legacy my channel is all
the spongebob games that I've played so
I have collected as many spongebob
related both horror and non horror games
that I could possibly find and it turns
out they're only horror ones and these
are the types of games that remind me of
like spongebob Slendy pants which if you
remember I played that oh so many years
ago
oh man and then just recently 3 a.m. at
coaster cabs anyway this is SpongeBob's
day of terror the first one to kick us
off you okay you spongebob are trapped
trapped in rock bottom hello oh I don't
have money saved
oh well I don't like the sound of this
Oh
oh that looks that's a nasty patty well
that don't look so good to me
what the Hoople is someone trying to
sell me something hey hey hey hey wait a
minute
[Music]
what don't understand ordinarily that
guy just wanted to talk to me Oh
kelp chips great Oh
I don't sound good someone's far enough
a storm behind me just ties it to my
wrist okay whatever you know what okay I
guess I'm safe oh I see hi let me wave
to you oh okay you're gone
I've waved him in to Oh God this might
be the greatest game I've ever played
sunglasses [ __ ] you I'll be cool uh-oh
that's not good good back up there back
up there Sonny Jim I'm in my safe space
hmm okay Oh God
this might just be the greatest game
I've ever played in my life
whoa spatula that looks valuable
oh well this is a problem for me hey hey
wait a minute no I just got enough money
I got enough money for a ticket don't
know boy oh okay you just gotta wave at
him and there's oh geez so uh oh
[Music]
have a ticket blip oh wow
okay what is that good did I make it at
it oh hey how's it going can I can I get
out of here oh yeah it was amazing oh
good it was surprisingly well-made for
what it was which was a great game full
of promise and hope all right okay
moving on okay so if you were worried
about the quality of these games don't
worry they only get better from here
what I mean laughs this is obviously
[Music]
the fire raining on their style ulama
lusco
ah okay I've no idea what's happening oh
hi Patrick
oh it's a Freddy's game oh ah oh ah
that's to look behind me I guess this is
oh no I can't see anything
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay let's try to take this seriously
huh let's try boy I think I'm supposed
to put my mask on when that happens
because otherwise otherwise I'll be in
trouble right why could I see Patrick on
the pooper gonna do any of that gonna do
me I don't know I don't understand
okay now Patrick's on the pooper I gotta
be watch out for mr. Krabs I guess I
suppose alright whatever you know what
[Music]
thanks for not spongebob I don't know
how to
what do I get a turn around why did
spongebob get exploded in the juice all
over the screen if they're gonna make
him go away with this I think they would
cover am i I guess I don't know you know
I don't know man I was just guessing
here
no can't oh that's how you doing oh this
is much easier than I thought it'd
better that I need something complex
timing or something Oh Patrick's out of
the pooper I'm ready for you batty boy
who are you no I got your number now
right
easy enough I guess so long as no one
sneaks up behind me but I don't know why
they would do that that seems awfully
rude chance
[Music]
go away Oh nah oh okay you know what I'm
thinking this ain't worth nothin it
ain't worth it
this game might actually be broken so
maybe there's no point in actually
trying to beat it
[Music]
okay okay okay all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
I guess
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know okay you don't thanks man
look out for mr. Krabs he can be a bit
more shall I say he's gonna be more
quirkier that your catchphrase I like
money
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh God that is a big mood though oh man
okay okay all right so there you have it
three wonderful wonderful spongebob
games mmm wonderful absolutely darling
I'll believe the two these games in the
description below if you would like to
see them for yourself please check them
out
they're well worth their time so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and if you've got other
games you'd like me to play maybe a
collage of a style of game let me know
in the comments below thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]